covering everything and yes black's
queen can come down to the g1 square and
check the white king but the white king
just moves the white king steps up the
board and oh wow offer of a queen trade
mishra really reacted there what do we
think can he just take the queens and
win this game
yes yes you think so simon put the
knight on g3 and win probably very good
and he does it yeah he's going for this
he's going to re-route his night now to
block this black pawn
okay he has to move he has to bring his
knight back look at the energy bopping
up and down mitchell is sensing that
this could be a huge moment in his
career
very excited isn't it you can tell he's
getting but i mean is this so clear
because the black king is going to make
its way to the center and those two
pawns are going down white had one extra
move if white's king could plant itself
in the center of the board just giving
itself one or two extra moves it's game
over white's pawns will win the game but
yeah it's a bit too slow black's king is
the first one there yeah max king is
coming it's always worrying when a
player picks the idea that i have